ليلى أخبرني لماذا أردت شراء 10
دراجات نارية
لأنني أردت واحدة ما تريده ليلى أوه
ليلى تصل إلى هنا وهي تجلس على
عرشها من الدراجات النارية خارج منزلها
في ويستبورت ماساتشوستس لقد طلبت أه
خمس دراجات نارية وردية اللون خمس
دراجات نارية زرقاء أه 10 أزواج من راعية البقر  أحذية
وسيارة جيب بقيمة تزيد عن ثلاثة آلاف دولار من
الأشياء الجيدة التي طلبتها بنفسها
ولم يكن لدى والدتها جيسيكا أدنى فكرة عن ذلك
بفضل أزرار أمازون،
زر كريس براون تقول جيسيكا إنها تتذكر
إعطاء ليلى هاتفها للعب بعض الألعاب
في السيارة أو هكذا هي  اعتقدت أنني
نظرت إلى الوراء في الوقت الذي كانت فيه الساعة 9:30 تقريبًا،
وهو بالضبط الوقت الذي كنا فيه في
السيارة، لذلك لم يكن الأمر احتياليًا، لقد كانت
هذه فقط الدراجات وسيارة الجيب التي خرجت
إلى حوالي 3180، وكانت الأحذية وحدها حوالي
600.  وبفضل الشحن الذي تقدمه أمازون لمدة يومين،
وصلت مكاسب Lila غير المشروعة
في وقت قصير على الإطلاق، وكانت هذه في الواقع
غير قابلة للإرجاع في الأصل، لكنني
تواصلت مع أمازون في الساعة الثانية
صباحًا وسألتني من فضلك إذا كان هناك
أي شيء  يمكننا أن نفعل ذلك، لقد ألزمونا في النهاية
وأرسلنا ملصقات الإرجاع
ولحسن الحظ أنها تمكنت من إلغاء
أحذية رعاة البقر هذه قبل مغادرتهم
المستودع أما بالنسبة لسيارة الجيب، فلا يزال لدينا
سيارة جيب عملاقة ذات مقعدين قادمة أيضًا
ولم أتمكن من إلغاء  طلب ولكنهم سيسمحون
لي بإعادته،
ستشعر بالحزن عندما
تختفي جميع الدراجات النارية، نعم بدلاً من
العقاب، تستخدم جيسيكا هذه
اللحظة التعليمية لابنتها، لقد
أخبرتها أنه ربما إذا كانت تعرف أنها تتصرف بشكل
صحيح  إنها تتصرف وتقوم ببعض
الأعمال المنزلية في جميع أنحاء المنزل بحيث يمكننا أن نوفر
لها دراجة أكثر ملاءمة
لفئتها العمرية بشكل أبطأ قليلاً ربما
فريق Leanna Falk NBC 10 News الليلي